[Music]
when homer's iliad was first written
down in the 8th century BCE the story of
the Trojan War was already an old one
from existing oral tradition audiences
knew the tales of the long siege the
epic duels outside the city walls and
the cunning trick that finally won the
war in the end the Magnificent city was
burned to the ground never to rise again
but had it ever existed by the time the
field of archaeology began to take shape
in the 19th century many were skeptical
considering the epic to be pure fiction
a founding myth imagining a bygone
heroic era but some scholars believed
that behind the superhuman feats and
divine miracles that there must have
been a grain of historical truth a war
that was really fought in a place where
it happened
Frank Calvert was one such believer he
spent his youth traveling and learning
about ancient civilizations before
accompanying his brother Frederick on a
diplomatic mission to the northwest
Anatolian region of China Callay it was
here that Homer described the Greek
encampment at the mouth of the scamander
River and it was here that fate brought
Frank into contact with a journalist and
geologist named Charles McClaren locals
and travelers had long speculated that
Troy might have stood on one of the
surrounding hilltops but McClaren had
been one of the first to publish a
detailed topographical study of the area
he believed he had found the site a 32
metre mound known by the name his
sarlaac derived from the Turkish word
for fortress soon after meeting with him
in 1847 the Calvert's bought 2,000 acres
of farmland that included part of the
hill before they could explore any
further the Crimean War broke out and
four stalled their archaeological
ambitions for several years after the
war's end
Frank Calvert began to survey the site
but lacked the funds for a full
excavation this was where the wealthy
German businessman and amateur
archeologist Heinrich Schliemann came
at Calvert's invitation Sleeman visited
the grounds in 1868 and decided to
excavate eager to find the ancient city
chalet Montour massive trenches all the
way to the base of the hill there he
uncovered a horde of precious artifacts
jewelry and metalwork including two
diadem's and a copper shield Sleeman
took full credit for the discovery
announcing that he had found troy and
the treasure of its king priam but the
real treasure was elsewhere when later
archeologists studied the site they
realized that the mound consisted of no
less than nine cities each built atop
the ruins of the last the layer
Schliemann had uncovered dated back to
the Bronze Age more than a thousand
years too early for Homer but inside the
mound was indeed evidence for a city
that had thrived during the Mycenaean
age with charge stone broken arrowheads
and damaged human skeletons suggesting a
violence and it was troy 7 contained in
the middle layers and now ravaged for a
second time by schliemann's careless
excavation the settlement spanning some
two hundred thousand square meters and
home to as many as 10,000 people thrived
until around 1180 BCE its position at
the southern entrance of the Dardanelles
Strait would have made a formidable
strategic location for both defense and
trade most importantly there are the
remains of a massive fortification wall
perhaps the very same one from which
Priam and Hector once watched the Greeks
approach of course it's difficult to be
certain that these ruins are the true
remains of ancient Troy and scholars
still dispute whether the Trojan War as
described by Homer ever happened yet the
evidence is strong enough that UNESCO
has labeled his Sarlacc the
archaeological site of Troy regardless
of its identity
thanks to persistence a bit of faith and
a lot of research archaeologists are
bringing the long buried secrets of an
ancient lost city to light
are you enchanted by the search for lost
cities so are we and that's why we love
fallen glory the lives and deaths of
history's greatest buildings thanks to
our partners at Picador for limited time
you can get a copy of your own at a
steep discount by clicking here or visit
ed Ted comm / books to learn more
[Music]